understanding South Africa's genocide
case against Israel part 4 how the world
is reacting many countries have openly
supported South Africa's case against
Israel including the 57 countries of the
organization of Islamic cooperation who
issued a statement of support and
accused Israel of quote indiscriminate
targeting of civilians other countries
that have publicly supported the case
are Bolivia Malaysia Pakistan Namibia
Nicaragua Venezuela meanwhile the West
has been pretty United in condemning
South Africa for this the United States
Israel's oldest Ally called the case
unproductive and the genocide
allegations unfounded Canada Germany and
the UK all insisted that Israel has the
right to defend itself and rejected the
genocide claims the French foreign
minister said that accusing Israel of
genocide quote crosses a moral threshold
ultimately it's this International
Court's job to decide if South Africa's
claims have any Merit but remember that
the court doesn't have any way of
enforcing it in part five I'll explain
what's next for this case